[Music]
[Applause]
Kenny Smith Three Times sports
semi-nominated analyst TNT inside the
NBA and he's written a book talk of
Champions TNT will present extensive
second round and exclusive Eastern
Conference Finals live game coverage
coming up good to see you again Kenny
you wrote a book how long has this been
in the works
uh you know it took about maybe 11
months to write 10 to 11 months of right
um it was very interesting because when
I first told Charles and Shaq I'm like
I'm writing a book and it's a tell-off
book and they were like what are you
talking about I was like no but it's
actually it's a book tell a book about
all the great things I learned from
great people and you guys a part of it
and what I did then was instead of like
having chapter one two three four five
it's it's chapters named after a
specific person Dean Smith Bill Russell
Jordan like all the people that I took
for granted that everybody had those
type of people in their in their life
and I'm like I was writing it then and
then and I'm sending in chapters and the
editor goes do you realize like every
chapter you're sending someone they have
a book writing about their life already
and I was like I I have a daily
interaction if I want to with these
people and I just want people to
understand why I feel better about
themselves when they read it and go oh
that's what makes me successful when I
do that the way Jordan did it or you
know whomever
well you you had a chapter when you went
to Sacramento and you talked about Bill
Russell Bill Russell's impact on you and
I loved it because it was his impact on
you as a man
not necessarily as a player and you
would want wisdom from Bill Russell the
greatest winner of all time but there's
so much more wisdom that he imparted
yeah and that's why he's the greatest
winner because the winning is not just
in one aspect of his life you know and
in a book I talked about it you know we
were sitting on a plane like one of the
stories we were sitting on the plane
and um
he he was the general manager and the
president of the team and the coach so
you know a lot a lot of responsibilities
and he's looking at this sheet and it my
my job as a rookie I had to sit next to
him on every plane ride and every bus
ride and so no one so that was my rule
his Rule and he's looking at these
players in Yugoslavia all over the place
and I go coach he's not a better player
in Alabama or the same like it flying
all the way over to Yugoslavia and he
stopped me right there and he's like
Kenny as an African-American you could
never not want inclusion
and I go whoa like he took a moment that
I was casually joking about and gave me
a life lesson and that was him and you
know so same thing with with like I said
with Michael and Charles like some of
these things are not bad most of them
are not basketball lessons it's the way
I shape myself as a parent financially
uh everything
Jordan is always fascinating because you
both went to North Carolina you're
passed across he goes to baseball you
end up winning two NBA championships
does how often does Jordan bring up if
he didn't go play baseball you'd have no
NBA titles
well first of all he did come back he
was wearing number 45 and when he had 55
points in Madison Square Garden nobody
was talking about he was Rusty only
until the Orlando Magic beat him then
they're like oh he's Rusty you know so
no he was back
um but I I just think that you know of
course in his heart he's gonna believe
that but I just think that our teams
would have beat them and I just won I
don't think that it's there's no
eight-year Champions that means he would
have won eight straight titles you don't
think they won eight straight no I don't
think and the documentary proved it
because there was so much internal
things that's why Horace Grant left and
so the fact that when Horace Grant
people forget those two years there was
no Dennis Rodman and no Horace Grant
that's why they lost to Shaquille and
and Orlando they were too small it
wasn't that Jordan wasn't the greatest
basketball player we still had seen like
they were just too small and they would
had no one that was big enough or good
enough to guard Akeem at those two years
and I think we would have won because of
that not because of not the lack of
Jordan's greatness there was no Grant
and then Rodman comes two years later
yeah then they go on that second
three-peat run now if they had those two
guys I might be scratching my house oh
yeah you know what I'm glad he went to
baseball a better Center in your mind
Hakeem or Shack
oh
I mean
I I don't know if it's better but what
was better for me would been a king
like because of the style of play that
he played he it allowed me to kind of
still you know be flourished and do
things that I do I think Shaq is so
dominant that you know at times you know
you become your role just keeps
decreasing uh so for me it's just better
playing with a king I would say that so
for me I would take a king I know that
uh Lebron with social media there's more
people that you know move in for the
kill and they're more critical with him
I'm wondering if people if they had
social media would they have gone after
Jordan the same the same way it feels
like social media it's either they're
with LeBron or they're against LeBron it
felt like everybody back when Mike
played
even if he was coming to your town you
went to see Mike and it was okay if he
beat your team I I wonder if so how he
would have done with social media and
vice versa I I it would be scary with
Michael with social media because
his popularity would be through the I
mean he was already the most
recognizable face in the world yeah you
know he was he's musically what I you
know I think I said this the other day
he's like he musically was what Michael
Jackson was like people would faint when
they just saw him like and social media
would have only expanded that for him
because because he was the first that we
we hadn't seen what he was doing we had
never seen that you know we've seen a
taste of it with Dr J
you know but we had never seen what
Michael was doing and social media would
have just exploded that even more uh on
it
um so yeah it would have been scary how
popular he would have been if so soon
here was there LeBron is great as he is
when he's at his greatest
he's taking a piece of something we've
already seen yeah so that's what doesn't
that's what might separates Michael
we're talking to Kenny Smith the book is
talk of Champions a uh three-time Sports
Emmy nominated analyst Mike Greenberg
brought this up that maybe the Lakers
should rest tonight rest their starters
tonight completely rest them
um I I wasn't sure against who
the kids and I was I didn't want to take
it out of context but I was thinking
could you imagine first of all the
commissioner wouldn't allow that
second of all Lebron's not going to
allow that
uh if you're down by you know 18 in the
fourth quarter then you could rest them
but could you imagine if the Lakers
actually said you know what we're going
to sit A.D and LeBron and rest him for
game six
that would be the most arrogant
display of disrespect of your opponent
that would ever be in the history of
basketball that when we talk about
respecting your opponent in the game
that would take it to such a level of
insanity and I'm not saying he's insane
who said it I'm saying the action of
that is insane because
what if in game six you you think you're
that much better than a team and you're
game six the first play of the game A.D
twists his ankle yeah
then what yeah
uh and and the other thing about this
the next two out of the next three games
if you can get to a game seven or in
Golden State yeah
so there are a bad Road team but they're
not a bad home team so
no way would you do that that would be
that would be Insanity like and then
tell the way might as well let's add
some more fuel to it and let them go to
Vegas to blow up some steam why sit out
there but but Harden got to go to Vegas
I know Rodman got to go to Vegas right
exactly exactly so let's add that to the
equation take a day off LeBron and AD go
to Vegas come back and we'll see you
later did you ever take a charge on Shaq
or Charles
I never took a charge but I I have with
with Shaq the ball was like a loose ball
and I didn't see him and he Dove for the
ball oh boy
and he hit me
and landed like like half of his body
landed
on my shoulder and my arms and I got a
rug bird
from the floor
based on his strength that lasted three
weeks I couldn't like I literally had to
wear a pad in practice because I
couldn't do it in a game but I had to
wear a pad in practice because it was so
tender because of his force that made me
he's an incredibly huge human being yes
he is but Yao Ming is bigger than Chuck
I don't think he had the same Force even
when he was as big yeah like Shaq's
force was still bigger
than Yao Ming good luck with the book
and uh we'll be watching Eastern
Conference Finals they'll have the uh
live game coverage the book is talk of
Champions he's Kenny Smith thank you
Kenny good to talk to you again
man good talking to you my brother all
right uh phone calls coming up
yeah they the chapter about Bill Russell
who I found really interesting because
I'm fascinated with Bill Russell the man